eric et a dû se rendre à l'évidence sa
convalescence ne s'est pas déroulé comme
il le souhaitait ses douleurs au dos
depuis sa chute à l'entraînement au
chili en septembre dernier ne l'ont pas
quittée il a tenté un retour en coupe du
monde à val gardena en décembre et a
fini 16e mais les images étaient
éloquentes
il était à l'arrivée plié en deux par la
douleur la paix à val gardena chantons à
la maison j'en lis tu comme un peu plus
de temps de récupération pour le cidre
et des collègues de doha commence à
m'entraîner au micro de radio canada
sports tout de suite après la course
eric savez peut-être qu'il n'irait pas
aux jeux olympiques je sais en a incité
paca va d'être entraînée à ça pour ça ce
n'est pas capable depuis cette course
erik guay s'était retranché chez lui à
mont tremblant entouré de ce qui compte
pour lui sur son compte instagram des
photos non pas d'un athlète se préparant
pour les jeux mais d'un père de famille
heureux d'être à la maison avec ses
quatre filles
malgré les blessures et les chutes
spectaculaires des a eu une carrière
remarquable au plus haut niveau
faites de succès et d'une volonté hors
du commun
les gens oublient qu aux jeux olympiques
de 2014 à sotchi
il pouvait à peine marcher blessé au
genou il a quand même réussi un top 10
en descente il a remporté cinq victoires
en coupe du monde
il est monté 25 fois sur le podium et a
remporté deux titres de champion du
monde
le second à saint moritz en 2017 en
super g
un moment de grâce qui lui a permis de
gagner aussi la médaille d'argent en
descente
ce sont mes derniers jeux ont mis un
accent bonne nouvelle eric gay n'a pas
annoncé sa retraite
sa saison est terminée mais pas sa
carrière il veut défendre son titre au
prochain championnat du monde fait les
pieds pour radio-canada à montréal